before Einstein came along space and
time were fixed they were absolute they
were given to us by Sir Isaac Newton and
they didn't do anything they were just
the background on which physics happens
and then when Einstein comes along he
says that you know what you and I think
of as gravity is actually rising because
space and time changed they're flexible
they're dynamical they can be curved
they can bend and this opens up a whole
new universe of possibilities and one of
the possibilities is that there can be
shortcuts through space and through time
and so that's really just what a
wormhole is it's taking advantage of the
fact that you can bend space and time in
arbitrary ways you just warp the space
in between two points to regions of
space that look like they're very far
apart from the outside world but there's
a shortcut through them because there's
a little tube that can be very very
short even though it connects these two
regions that are very far away now do
you need in a huge mass to warp the
space well the honest answer is you
can't do it sure you can
the thing is that we can talk about what
it would be like if you could do it and
general relativity is a very flexible
pun not intended theory it lets you talk
about all sorts of things that can
happen because what it says is given
these kinds of energy this is how space
and time would react so for a wormhole
you need kinds of energy that we don't
know how to produce it's not a matter of
how much energy in fact it's not even a
lot of energy it's a negative amount of
energy we don't know how to do that
the embarrassing fact is that we don't
know whether you can make wormholes or
not because general relativity as good
as it is Einstein smart guy going places
but he's not the final word on how
gravity works we don't understand the
ultimate laws of physics so maybe they
will allow us to do so it gives science
fiction writers hope and the tool to use
so will you tell us about that every
science fiction writer who wants to get
out of the solar system and
fewer than you know months or years
ghulam Jean gloms onto that or some
variation of that because it's it's you
know it's the cheat or it's the maybe
you know it's it's the leap of faith
that that lets you tell stories on this
bigger canvas in our case the nine
realms whatever whatever you want to
call them the Vikings in space the
Vikings in space now what so when you're
writing writing science fiction you
which you have done a lot of I
understand right yeah my partner and I
seem to be doing this a lot yes you when
you can do you try and incorporate
realistic or at least you know
borderline theoretical stuff that makes
gives the sense of possibility as much
as you can yeah absolutely because when
ash and I approach science fiction when
were when we're writing screenplays we
view science and the laws of physics and
things like that where we can as rules
okay and as limits and rules and limits
are what you produce drama from if your
superhero doesn't have limits on what he
can do or she can do then anything can
happen but if all of the sudden you
you're putting limitations on where they
can go how much they can lift how fast
they can go that that causes
vulnerabilities and that causes that
causes places where they can't do things
and that's where you get excitement and
dramatic scenes from I mean you've
already Illustrated with these so-called
realistic heroes right that that really
when you come down to it a space Viking
with a flying hammer is really not any
less realistic than then a guy who
doesn't get reduced to a pulp each time
he comes to you know and that was the
big challenge when when ash and I were
brought on board and it was it was okay
you need to integrate Thor into the
bigger Marvel Universe because we're
building towards the Avengers and how do
you do that given the cosmic nature of
Wrath and the kind of tools that that
Sean is talking about einstein-rosen
bridge using physics and using that
great arthur c clarke quote
that we that we paraphrased and abused
any any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
is a great hand wave because as as you
pointed out things that we take for
granted now to people a thousand years
ago would have looked like wizardry and
magic and things like that so we don't
have to explain how Thor's hammer works
does it have a little motor inside of it
or no it was it was forged in the heart
of a dying star I think Anthony Hopkins
II you know by dwarf neutron star